極めて総務ないぞ
リップしょうもないヴィッツの方が高く売れるいやぁ今回は極めて勝負内でも少なから
ずになってる人はいるかた客に何だろうみたいな
ああああっんぴノート貸して1個の p のにしてみたいぴょですねコンビニで一番
いいリバティ
[拍手]
ほら方鍋山まあコンビニエンスストアーということがあるわけじゃないですかね
もっさい方が最近根源にはパンツ売ってます総肝管つなんですね
日常生活なら基本的に何でも大変じゃないかぐらいいろんなものがあるんですけども
逆にもう過ぎてひょっとしたら不必要なものがあるんじゃないかっていうキャッチャー
やってる犬の餌とかこれですよねーじゃん
必要としてる人いますちょっとそういうことだということその必要とかさあはかんだ
言い訳でじゃないですか我々はそこにもして今でもいいんですけども4人で1人1品
ずつ入れ替え嫌な客とたもいるんだよ全部ますよねその中でもコンビニで一番これは
いただきだろうって優先度をつけた上で一番いらないものを持ってきてロニーで今日
上下結果民で一番いらないものだ1を決めよう恐竜意味で逆にコンビニ遊んだろうって
んだって売らんですけど役に立つかもしれないし
それだけですピーリングいや結構するんじゃないん
第二ないけどまぁその場に行かないとわからないからなぜこれが入らないかなうーん
ベッドいっ
[音楽]
をどうだもんでコンビニで一番入れないと思われそうなものを準備したので首都理由と
一緒に説明していただきましょう
後輩さんからいきましょう
[音楽]
ブーブーいやーよくしたねこれすごい
売ってるそれなんだろうだろうとこらえ買ったのは
はい多分ちってきたらうーんって思ってたんじゃないんだろうかっていうものを今
どうぞ
それがこちらです
[音楽]
あっ肌が十分でない夢をも話題になってコンビってさーこ
マンがあると思ってさあ校6編絶対600円なんでしょ
てかいロッペンで動いてるんだよ手にとってこう
熟読セラっていうことがほぼ無いんじゃないかなんですけどねぇねぇぞ
これ全部一定の需要があるかもしれないで言って昔に難しいところである
いつかはいありませんかどうぞ
[音楽]
インスタートカメラああ
中島多分デジカメ乗ってなくてもみんなスマホとか整体師たるから多分いらないと思う
上でなさそうだねそう言ってから振っ振ってなさそうエピソード指いい
さっきこれ買った時にもうこのバーコードがで家で反応するってよね直感カメラの専門
家から言いますと
ですね最近頃流行ってますまじ
女の子の間で始まるカメラっていうのはそう流行ってて今なんかポスターがおっしゃ
れるばいいので
最近需要が高まってでしょう私が思ったコンビニでこれはいらねえんだと思うのは
こちらです
一番違ってえーっ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーブーしかあっあっああっ日本茶
全部ウソまあ
なぜ俺原っコンビなでうちも実家コンビニでっていう
あいーバンケットで言ってくれなかったを切れた後にター
更新とかを
やった俺3
7000観客あったなコンビニ行ってた時からするとコンビニで自賠責はあんまりい
なかったしてきたとしても店員さんは困っ新しいトートはバイクが多いからさーん普通
の人からすると
じゃないじゃん
ねっ
ホント0ファン投票でね麻生
第1回コンビニでいらないものを制して第1話
のはえ
をアップ鳳凰これじゃあん
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ